[Music]
anybody seen the bus keys where'd you
leave them for 45 minutes right here
another girl that's real irresponsible
Vic I bet Aquaman never loses his keys
two more minutes Rita then I'm taking it
off the hinges damn what did you do
Larry I didn't do anything it was him it
well could you tell him to undo it but
we're not exactly on speaking terms at
the moment when in fact I think he may
be trying to kill me they have been
useful information to have before we let
you try don't yell at him it's not his
fault he has no control over that thing
yes I do
I will
I'll get it under control impressive
leadership skills there Batman way to
rally the team justice please 2020 hey
hey ain't you cyborg how you doing sir
yeah what's Batman really like I
wouldn't know never met the guy
really hey Jenny Justice League sir I
don't really need to get this bus fixed
hey no problem bobble hey names ring
Dean copy that damn it Superfriends hey
everybody it's Charlie we got a whole
bunch of news about Titan season two
Superboy they finally cast their actor
in there been a whole bunch of Easter
eggs between Titans and Doom Patrol
which are connected shows I'll explain
what's going on with that but obviously
all the jokes about Justice League in
there just let you know kind of what's
going on with the team in this current
version of the universe will do a new
round of that DC streaming service
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Superboy or Doom Patrol in the
video I'll explain the Titans season -
Superboy stuff first then I'll talk
about Justice League and Doom Patrol
stuff because obviously everyone is
wondering whether or not cyborg is ever
gonna join the Titans and what's going
on with the actual Justice League but
what happened recently is they finally
cast their actor so that's sort of like
post-credit scene for titan season 1 is
there teaser for season 2 and Superboy
like that's the big new character that
they're introducing so as you could
probably tell we just got done watching
the first half of young just
season three Titans is doing the Young
Justice Superboy origin story for this
version of Conner Kent instead of doing
the straight-up comic-book Superboy
origin story there's really only one
minor difference between those two
origin stories and in the Young Justice
version Superman is still alive because
in the comic book origin story for
Superboy he busted out of STAR Labs when
Superman was believed to be dead after
doomsday supposedly killed him
reign of the Superman was the debut of
Conner Kent Superboy in the comics so
Young Justice just sort of tied that off
a little bit and said nope Superman is
still alive so he gets to actually meet
Conner Kent for the first time and be
really creeped out by him they took my
DNA in Lex Luthor's and made a baby with
it what I don't even want to think about
this Superman on Young Justice didn't
want to have anything to do with Conner
Kent right away so don't be surprised if
they do the same thing for Titans
version of Conner Kent where Superman
just isn't quite aware of what's going
on right away until they start
investigating him and then they learn
about the Lex Luthor of everything and
that turns into a couple season arc the
actor that they cast to play him is
named Joshua orphan he's an Australian
he's about 25 years old which sounds
about right for Conner Kent Superboy so
what'll happen is he'll be a main
character during season two he's already
started posting pictures of himself this
is actually meant to be a comic book
Easter Egg for Conner Kent when he
debuted during reign of the supermen all
punk-rock there were also a couple
Easter eggs for Titans Superboy on the
recent episode of Doom Patrol there's a
news broadcast in STAR Labs Detroit the
cyborg is looking at and there's a whole
bunch of news headlines which are Easter
eggs for all the DC streaming service TV
shows the first one is the Superboy one
so this lets you know that this is
happening after the Titans post-credit
scene and it just reads metropolitan
father pleads not guilty to charges an
i-94 crash that led to five deaths
claims naked man with dog hit his car
the naked man and his dog are Superboy
and Krypto Adam he busted them out of
Cadmus labs in Metropolis they're just
on the run now so we will get more
Easter eggs about that later in Doom
Patrol season or we'll just see them
show up at the beginning of Titan's in
the trailers that they release at Comic
Con this summer the other Easter egg in
there too is the road I 94 that's when
Connor can't Superboy debut during the
death of Superman in the reign of
Superman so just a whole bunch of
Superboy Easter eggs that are probably
gonna be popping up real soon
the rest of these news headlines are all
Easter eggs for Titans stuff and some of
the other shows too so it's a 39 year
old woman found dead in house in
Traverse City Michigan that's actually
from Titans pilot that's Ravens foster
mother that was dead that's where she's
from Traverse City Michigan the chaos
and clover ten one is actually the
events of Doom Patrol episode one than
the one at the bottom about the dazed
and confused brazilian woman with
glowing green eyes might be fire Beatriz
DaCosta from the comics that might be a
Doom Patrol thing that might be a Titans
Easter Egg it could be for the
swampthing TV show but I think the Swamp
Thing show is supposed to really be its
own thing in the way that Titans in do
patrol are kind of meant to be connected
I think they said that Swamp Thing isn't
going to crossover with the other TV
shows on DC Universe but we'll get more
information about that soon if you've
been watching do patrol you probably
seen all the cyborg stuff so this
version of cyborg seems like he was not
created using a mother box unless
they're lying to us and there's some
mystery that he'll learn about over the
course of the season because in the
first couple of episodes that he debuts
he's a relatively young version of the
character his father operates out of
STAR Labs Detroit they're sort of the
money that backs a lot of what's going
on during Doom Patrol early on but he
has this special corporate jet they have
all these research patents so he's
really rich that's where a lot of their
money comes from to fund their missions
you also probably notice big Smallville
Easter Egg is that his father Silas
stone is played by Martian Manhunter
from Smallville but his father is
grooming him to try and join the Justice
League someday so he's not super hot on
what's going on with the Doom Patrol
team I don't know what their long-term
plan is for cyborg if he'll eventually
go to Titans it makes sense that they
would cross him over eventually even if
he's not a permanent team member on
Titans robot-man and crazy Jane or sort
of the sass of the group so you have all
those clips of robot man referencing
Justice League characters I bet Aquaman
doesn't lose his keys nice job rallying
the team Batman really great in a crisis
Justice League 2020
I don't ever recall hearing a direct
shout out to Superman on any of the TV
shows yet but I think they were waiting
for a Conner Kent Superboy to come on
before they started referencing a lot of
Superman Easter eggs but in the first
couple of episodes of Titans you do see
dove wearing a Superman t-shirt letting
you know that he does exist in this
universe but you can kind of tell from
the first couple of episodes of Doom
Patrol how they're envisioning their
team versus
like the Justice League characters which
are like the gold standard a listers
that only deal with the biggest of
problems the really cosmic threats that
might also be why they're steering a
little away from mother box and cyborg
origin story stuff there are a couple
weird things that they haven't
completely explained with his backstory
he keeps finding false memories like his
father is tampering with his memory core
so they may have secretly actually done
the real comic book origin story there
may actually be some more cosmic stuff
at play here that we'll find out about
later but it seems like they're just
kind of teasing that out episode by
episode they did actually give Doom
Patrol a couple extra episodes this
season I guess they just thought that
the quality was so good that they
ordered a couple of extra ones instead
of doing the Titans thing where they
chop off the last episode that was
actually supposed to be twelve episodes
for Titans they filmed twelve then just
did not air the last one and recut
episode 11 to sort of cut it off at a
certain point because I guess they want
to leave some resolution to the Trigon
arc for the beginning of season 2 I
don't know how fast they're gonna blow
through that arc but they just started
filming Titan season 2 so like Donna
Troy Wonder Girl is gonna be another
main cast member
she's been beefing up in the gym
obviously they're doing Superboy because
I did the video about him and if you
weren't sure Jason Todd is also coming
back to the actor that played Jason Todd
was just teasing that he's also beefing
back up to get ready to start filming
season 2 again
I don't know how many episodes he's
gonna be in I'm assuming probably a
little bit more than he was in during
season 1 just because they had to spend
the first couple of episodes introducing
the core characters then they were able
to start introducing the other secondary
characters like Jason Todd Donna Troy
all the other cool people I'm sure
they'll be even more during season 2 as
of right now there have been no
announcements about when Doom Patrol is
gonna hit Netflix internationally for
all you people that live outside the
United States what might be happening is
you know conspiracy theory put your
tinfoil hats on is that because Warner
Brothers is rolling at another streaming
service for all of its content including
all the Warner Brothers library of
movies they might be saving a lot of the
DC Universe content for that instead of
sending it to Netflix for international
people and they might just roll that out
internationally
either way the reason why we probably
haven't heard any news about that is
probably because Netflix is worried
about that too and it's just trying to
negotiate on price but until we get some
more details I'm just assuming that
it'll be a fair
a similar situation to titans where it's
on the DC streaming service in the
United States and then everywhere else
in the world it's on Netflix I think it
took about a month for episodes to drop
on Netflix after the episodes finished
on the DC streaming service so just
assume the same thing for all the other
TV shows so if you live outside the
United States and you want to watch the
episodes right when they drop you're
gonna have to find an alternative method
for getting all that stuff so just good
luck to you hopefully that answers some
of the big questions about where stuff
is and when it's dropping right now I
think they're supposed to be fifteen or
sixteen episodes of Doom Patrol and then
all the rest of the Young Justice season
3 episodes will drop I believe at the
beginning of June but if I get any news
about that I'll post an update in a
video so no worries post all your Doom
Patrol and Superboy reactions in the
comments while you wait for everything
click here for two brand new x-men Dark
Phoenix trailers and click here for my
new Game of Thrones season 8 teaser
breakdown thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight